hey guys how's it going I really planned
on making a really great video for you
today but i don't think i've slept in
five six days maybe more I'm it's
Alabama for hangout fest and then from
hanging out fest I came back to LA and
then from la the same day I flew to
Seattle to go just eating you xbox one
reveal it's been a really crazy couple
of days but I documented my way back
from Alabama to see ya idol I think I
don't even remember what footage i shot
but I side to cut it all together and
share it here with you guys I did one of
these on my other I just speaking
channel on the way to alabama so i can
check that out on you could do that here
lot of the guys thought it was pretty
cool so I'm sharing this with you here
and then I'm gonna go to sleep for four
days so good night we're gonna drop this
you drop it my dog spends about oh my
gosh you got it she cut it again
Justin
that's awesome
hello travel log it is 335 a.m. central
time i woke up at two thirty slept for a
couple of hours ready to begin the trek
back to Los Angeles see how this day go
now is 345 am i'm having my Ellie
Goulding interview on Tiger buter from
MTV hard drive a little travel check in
here it's now 356 hello we're driving to
Florida we just entered florida by da
manhã alabama so goodbye alabama we had
a great time hold up to the scene with
muscle emission pulled up to the team
with muslim mrs. Gallardo j 4 30 at the
airport this is my bag this is my chores
bag I think I'm pathetic by the 5am at
the airport checked in ready to go no
we've got a breakfast 812 am here in
Atlanta
petfinder gate 18 will go down
escalators elevators
they're all the same at this would not
27 we're boarding now
11-50 am
those pants are great oh look at--look
camo now suppose three till 16 were in
the car peugeot Spataro they didn't put
his bag in the car 103 p.m. I'm home the
time is it what time is it what time is
it Cora 34 when we were really poor
dharti finishing packing cuz we took a
nap and then we're gonna head to the
airport so here we go the time he's
about 50 9pm I was hoping that we would
be the airport by now but it's only
think about 5 30 i'm gonna be a very
happy travel I've been in five cities
today after the lands yeah yeah that's
what I'm excited 5 30-6 p.m. we did it
we get these leggings with this suitcase
and this bag can I just get me show them
what this looks like
it's wonderful okay so I'm in the
airport right now I don't even know what
time it is but look at this oh my
goodness I got worse look at this do you
want to try it um ok here you go
micra luggage luggage meet scooter okay
you're definitely not as good as he is
on it you you're gonna need a little
more practice but that's pretty solid
yeah I don't know miss the ball so I
heard him talking run this in flight and
I ordered one on amazon because guys how
good a nice meeting you look I'm getting
this is just the best day of my it's 831
a.m. on tuesday i forgot to update you
guys when we landed yesterday me time
can we make it back to the hotel yes we
landed in 10-15 we're going to the xbox
event now right behind me is the xbox
reveal 10 we were about to go in design
people in glen people like this come
we're going in
Wednesday 447 am on way to the airport
sleepy and 535 am I have found Bigfoot
father beat him up if I gotta fight you
would do nothing of the sort 641 of you
11 a.m. wednesday i'm home end of
travelogue for real Pittsburgh are you
with Bruno Mars I'll be with Bruno yeah
we're touring at we stopped at the end
of june so yeah I always see you post
tons of instagrams what's your favorite
app of all-time I'm killing it on the
Instagram right now